let's bring in Dan Shaughnessy does a
great job covering baseball for the
Boston Globe baseball hall-of-famer Dan
is it a broadcasters responsibility to
be in the clubhouse as David Price
suggests I think it doesn't hurt but I
don't think it's a required especially
when you spend twenty four years in the
big leagues in clubhouse tennis actually
has I mean this is a phony argument by
Christ I'm not buying it I mean I'm in
the clubhouse all the time they don't
want you there and I understand why in
many cases but you know the notion is
they expect X players to be good to
players and when it doesn't happen and
again it's not been highly critical
about 10 seconds commentary it's very
blunt and candid and he says a million
good things when good things happen if
somebody doesn't do the job he'll call
him on it same as he'll call it on
himself this was the most stand-up guy I
think I ever covered in the big leagues
go back and look at what he did after he
gave up the gibson home run the one in
the dodger you know world series 1988 he
took wave after wave of reporters he
never made excuses he deflected
criticism of other guys took it on
himself and it's too bad ugly for David
Price too you know he's also told us
some people don't understand how hard
this game is that is so upside down it
should be on the Bale what do you think
is that the root of prices issues with
Eckersley is it one particular comment
is it a combination of comments I think
there's an overall feeling in that room
that he's too critical because you know
Remy and rice are not as critical Tim we
have a lot of xx ox guys who give
commentary and they just expect players
to say all the things and cover up their
mistakes and I think that's not what
you're going to get with Eckersley and
that's the fans like that it's better
that way so it doesn't wash well with
the players necessarily and I think that
David's just doesn't like the way he
gets talked about himself and it's using
this notion that he's standing up for
his teammates nobody asked him to stand
up for them and to try to embarrass a
guy hall-of-famer on a plane like that
and then to not you know to not have the
manager or other teammates say hey
that's not the way we do things here
which would be the correct way to handle
this that hasn't been done it's the only
reason they turn a one-day story into a
1-month story and why do you think that
the Red Sox particularly John Farrell
have taken sort of in
ambiguous position and bibble insane
this issue feral as as said he has not
spoken Eckersley he has not apologized
to Eckersley why do you think the Red
Sox er are taking this approach John
Farrell's either afraid the player or he
agrees with them either case it's not
good now above Farrell there's been all
kinds of apologies you know the owners
Sam Kennedy the CEO Dave Dombrowski can
all said the right thing not going to do
things here but they don't seem to have
the power over their two hundred and
seventeen million dollar picture to make
that happen so again the thing is still
sitting there and fans are pretty much a
hundred percent behind Eckersley and
zero behind price which is not good the
teams lost 14 out of 22 they don't need
this distraction players are getting
asked to applaud and who didn't you
notice it's become way way bigger one
stupid thing has become way bigger they
could have made it all go away
so I had an Shaughnessy Boston Globe
colonist joining us here on the Dan
Patrick show how does this get resolved
or doesn't get resolved I mean Eckersley
was in Cooperstown over the weekend is
he back on the job
this week do you think of any lingering
issues moving forward well equities in
what they call the legend suite at
Fenway tomorrow it's a ceremonial thing
they'll put Dwight Evans and bring guys
back and give the night with fans in the
suite upstairs and they they show on the
big board during the game when that
happens tomorrow will be like Bill
Belichick and Brady or they're on the
big board and some probably a nice
reception he's back on the booth on
Thursday it was talked about a meeting
with price and Eckersley I don't think X
isn't supposed to meet with a guy who is
thus far not apologetic still calling
him out for not being in the clubhouse
and basically clueless about the whole
situation one of the things that I
wonder when this person went down Dan
was you know there was a vacuum kind of
left behind when David Ortiz left that
clubhouse do you think this would be
happening if Ortiz was around I do not I
mean lt's was at the ballpark yesterday
Davis done a nice job staying clear this
year because you know he doesn't want to
be a distraction he has not been he came
by yesterday to help on of the 2007
champs he was part of that and in the
course of it was asked a lot of
questions and and said yeah he said he
likes everybody but he said he had dated
apologized at the end part of all this
is that you know David Price is hurt on
the DL with the the elbow problems how
significant are these elbow issues for
rice yeah that's really the larger
baseball story here and that's what they
should be talking about now right now
it's you know he didn't pitch in spring
training took two months off he's never
had elbow trouble led the nature's
meetings last year so there was concern
you know 31 years old never he really
had an issue there and all the money
still owe to him so they went slowly he
didn't go for Tommy John that seemed
good and then when he made his debut he
got better each time or command so they
had that great outing eight innings of
shutout ball against the Yanks on
national TV a couple of Sundays ago then
he had a stinker in Anaheim on a late
Saturday kind of got lost and and then
he was blocking on him he said and they
put him on the deal before his start at
home last Friday so they're saying he's
going to pick up a ball in a day or two
and give it a shot and then I think they
can pitch him later in the homestand or
if it's bad in the back Andrews and
explore right now they're trying to
minimize the extent of this and they're
going to need him to get where they want
to go the last two months
John Farrell in any trouble out there
well wouldn't be good they'll make a
playoff so if they got broomed out in
the first round again like they did last
year I think that would be bad for him
but they have the best team and then I
play in that way so that's never a good
thing it's five years here he's got a
chance to finish first or the third time
in five years that would be pretty good
and that would give him quite a bit of
solidarity you would think but they need
to do better in October than they did
last year hey always great to visit with
you Dan
appreciate the time anytime take care
Stan Shana covered the Red Sox at the
Boston Globe the Dan Patrick show
weekday mornings on audience